There are 440,000 children in
our foster care system right now,
and almost every state reports that there is a
shortage of families willing to care for them.
Fortunately, in recent years, a growing number
of churches and faith-based organizations
have revolutionized the way we recruit, train,
and support families. First, these churches
understood that sharing a picture of a foster
child on the nightly news was not very effective.
Instead, their pastors have begun telling their
congregations about children in their zip code
who need homes now. Second, they began to
offer training sessions at more convenient
times and places, and they supplemented that
training with a religious understanding of
the importance of caring for these children.
Finally, they provided a supportive community.
Half of foster parents quit within the first
year, many because they are working in a vacuum.
So these communities recruited
volunteers to offer respite care,
help build furniture at the last minute, and
provide spiritual support to foster families.
Other communities can learn a lot from these
examples. Would you consider fostering a child
in need? Let us know in our poll. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.